alright so we've brought back in
Jonathan to talk a little bit more about
how to move forward with envision making
better prototypes to start with how
would you go about making a higher
fidelity prototype than our current sort
of clickable prototype in envision sure
there's a couple of ways you can do this
Jay the first way is we have this option
called overlays so you can make like a
modal window or a drop-down menu and you
simply basically need to mock up a
section of your screen or an image of
the section of your screen and upload
that as a separate screen and envision
will allow you to use that screen as an
overlay on top of any existing screen so
that would be one method another method
is you can use advanced animations
through animated gifts an animated gif
we accept in envision so that you can
demonstrate an advanced interaction
right so as an example our current like
navigation drawer we could use that as
an overlay and it would just sort of
show up actually on top of the other
screens sure that's a great example
perfect so what are some other tools
within envision that we can use to sort
of make better programs what other
options are there sure there are a
number of different options in envision
that allow you to share out the project
to see the workflow or the progress of
your screens as you move it through the
the time or the life cycle of your
project we also have a feature called
boards that allows you to showcase your
designs in different formats so for
example if you have a prototype that you
have in a in a website but then you also
want to display it in a mobile phone or
a tablet you can display all those in a
single board right okay that makes
perfect sense and then are there sort of
best practices for doing user research
with these clickable and vision
prototypes that's a great question the
best practice is to turn off hotspot
hinting that's an advanced feature when
you share out a share link so when you
click the share link button there's an
advanced option that allows you to then
turn off hotspot hinting or prevent
hotspot ending this allows a user to
then
view the prototype either on a mobile
device or on a desktop computer and
click around and interact but they're
not prompted with your hot spots because
otherwise you'll get feedback that may
not necessarily be natural or organic
right because you'll have you know maybe
a tiny hot spot but if it's brought out
in blue and the user is like oh well
clearly that's a thing because it's
bright blue square over this image
exactly yeah preventing those sort of
prompts or tips to the user is always
best because you want the user to give
you the most natural feedback that they
would otherwise give you in a normal
environment right you don't want to
optimize this app for being shown in
this format you want to optimize the app
for being used exactly awesome thanks
for coming in giving us so much insight
thanks for having me